Vous avez été près de 500 000 sur
Figaro Live à suivre en direct le
premier lancement de SpaceX vers l'ISS samedi 30 mai à 21h22 merci à
vous merci aux commentateurs de la
Société Astronomique de France qui
étaient avec nous. Alors on se retrouve
le lendemain de ce décollage historique
pour faire un point sur le voyage des
deux astronautes qui ont réussi leur
amarrage à l'ISS à l'heure où nous
postons cette vidéo. Nous allons voir
comment s'est passé leur voyage avec
les premières images des astronautes Bob et Doug
dans l'espace à bord de la capsule Crew
Dragon,
jusqu'à l'amarrage c'est-à-dire l'accrochage de la capsule à l'ISS.
Mais avant je dois vous montrer la
réaction d'un homme
c'était hier soir au décollage et cet
homme
ces Elon Musk le patron de SpaceX
Je salue le travail incroyable des gens de SpaceX et de la Nasa
Le lancement incroyable d'aujourd'hui permet de remettre des astronautes en orbite
pour la première fois (pour les USA) depuis près de 10 ans
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui doit toucher les gens au cœur
au cœur de quiconque à l'esprit d'exploration.
Je veux être clair, la mission n'est pas encore finie
c'est un vol test, nous n'en sommes qu'au début
mais jusque là tout se passe très bien
et nous sommes content de voir que Bob et Doug, nos héros américains,
sont en sécurité en orbite, en chemin vers l'ISS.
Et justement, voyons comment s'est déroulé le voyage des deux astronautes
qui a duré 19 heures, un
voyage durant lequel ils ont effectué
divers tests, je rappelle que c'est la
première fois que SpaceX envoie des
humains vers l'ISS et ils ont aussi
un peu fait le show
On m'a demandé de faire un salto arrière, je vais faire une rotation latérale
une petite variation par rapport à cette demande.
Nous n'avons pas décollé seuls, Doug et moi. Nous avons avec nous
un apatosaure à bord de la capsule
Nous sommes tous les deux papas
et nos garçons adorent les dinosaures.
Et enfin nous y voilà
le 31 mai à 16h16 (heure française).
Nous sommes à 400 km de la
surface de la terre l'ISS tourne autour
de la Terre à la vitesse de 27 000 km/h
et la capsule va s'amarrer
Ce n'est pas une capsule russe, Soyouz,
qui s'amarre à l'ISS, comme c'était le cas
depuis 2011, on se souvient, par exemple,
du voyage du français Thomas Pesquet
en 2016 avec Soyouz. Vous faisiez peut-être partie des 3 millions de personnes qui
avaient suivi ça à l'époque sur Figaro
Live mais cette fois-ci c'est bien la
capsule américaine de SpaceX.
Voilà, l'équipage de Crew Dragon
a rejoint les trois occupants qui étaient
déjà dans la Station spatiale internationale
un américain, Chris
Cassidy et deux russes
Anatoli Ivanichine  et Ivan Wagner.
On ne sait pas encore exactement combien de temps ils vont rester,
plusieurs semaines, le patron de la Nasa a parlé d'un possible retour
au début du mois d'août 2020.
En tout cas, abonnez-vous pour ne rien
rater, car évidemment on suivra ça
en direct sur Figaro Live.